all right we are now live for another
monthly political theory and practice
discussion
and what we're going to be talking about
this time is in a broad sense the topic
of free speech but we're going to be
looking at it in light of a few things
let me actually clean this a little bit
there we go much much better you can
tell i'm a person who uses my laptop a
lot so we're going to be talking about
this recent new york times editorial and
some of the claims
and arguments and attitudes about this
notion of free speech
that are involved with it and i also
want to bring in another
piece that i came across recently medium
that i'll talk about in a bit
and then i'll also be discussing
um jon stewart mill and on liberty and
some of the
key ideas that he's making in this
classic document that centers around
freedom of speech
and the the biggest thing that we're
considering here can be encapsulated
in
i suppose a sentence
does a right to free speech preclude
other people from using their free
speech to
criticize or even to shun and to
shame the person who originally said
something probably bone-headed or
foolish or offensive or pick whatever
else you want and and the answer really
is
not if you want to be consistent about
free speech and i think that it should
be a really major value
in any sort of you know good faith
politics and and i think that it's it's
fine to exclude people who are not in
good faith or to reduce them to a lower
level uh in involved in discussions
if you're going to be in good faith then
you need to be consistent about free
speech so this is
a interesting and significant
significant
issue
and i do want to say a few things uh
right off the bat before we get into
looking at the editorial so free speech
is an ambiguous term right and what do
we mean in saying it's an ambiguous term
it has multiple meanings and it's very
easy for people who are involved in
discussions to
switch up the meanings or to confuse
them and move from one to the other
particularly if they're not actually
engaging in good faith discussion with
other people um so this is this is a
really important thing to point out at
the very beginning aristotle points out
something very similar in the nick of
mccann ethics when he's talking about
justice right justice itself is an
ambiguous term why do people get into so
many arguments about justice and
injustice well they don't realize that
they're using it in
different ways
so
another thing that's important to keep
in mind and this is where free speech
gets really really complicated
is that it's also what we can call
reflexive that is it applies to itself
so debating about advocating clarifying
arguing about even many ways of limiting
free speech is inevitably using some
measure of free speech so free speech is
used in the very engagement uh in
talking about it like we're doing here
you know this this is not an unlimited
free speech zone obviously if you act
like a complete jerk you're going to get
booted you know there's some things that
you shouldn't be engaging with you know
because we're going to have a relevant
discussion
um but you know we're using free speech
and we're using a platform of free
speech that is youtube in order to have
this conversation so let's let's talk
about the new york times editorial um
[Music]
it's called america has a free speech
problem
and there's lots of points and arguments
there because it's a rather long piece
and it struck a lot of people
as soon as it came out including myself
as rather tone deaf and pearl clutching
and inconsistent and i would actually go
so far as to say at least in one central
claim that it's making just batshit nuts
you know
and it's interesting before we go into
those claims i want to say this so
immediately it started a lot of
discussion going on in social media and
i noticed something you know in in
twitter where i you know posted about it
and responded about it and also even
posted my stuff about jon stewart mill
for people who wanted it as resources
a lot of the replies were oh yeah i mean
this is really bonkers crap here uh what
is the new york times thinking
and same thing in linkedin and same
thing on youtube and the one place
where uh people were like oh i think the
new york times is perfectly on point
here who are you to be you know
criticizing them and all that
it was facebook and it was on my
facebook page where people were weighing
in and they're saying i read the new
york times piece i didn't see anything
that seemed out of out of place there
and i was like
re-read it read it and think about it uh
and then they they would say well i
reread it and i was like well you know
i don't know what to say to you then
so
um we'll we'll go on from that by the
way people avoid hyperbole in in your
your remarks here because you know we
want to be on point right all political
wings have become pure sophistry very
disheartening andrew's saying that
that's not the case i mean if or if you
do want to say stuff like that i mean
imagine that people are going to use
their free speech to weigh in and say
yeah that's that a that's not really a
good uh
a good accurate representation about
things let's try to avoid hyperbole here
right as much as we can
so let's take a look at the
um
the claims that are being made here so
the first thing that they're saying in
the very first sentence
quote for all the tolerance and
enlightenment that modern society claims
americans are losing hold of a
fundamental right as citizens of a free
country the right to speak their minds
and voice their opinions in public
without fear of being shamed or shunned
so i want to repeat that last bit
the right
to speak their minds and voice their
opinions in public without fear
of being shamed or shunned now when you
read that you're like did they just
invent a new write in the first line of
this editorial
um you know and it reminds me of that
that thing uh that has become kind of a
meme from mean girls you know when
gretchen is trying to make fetch happen
they say you can't you're not going to
make fetch happen uh just by you saying
it doesn't make it so it's kind of a
weird thing that the new york times
instead of actually making an argument
for this vast vast claim
uh that we have a right to speak our
minds and voice opinions in public
without fear
of being shamed or shunned
they just threw it out there and what
this shows is that they they must
believe that there is such a
right
so there's this question of did they
just invent a right and we'll talk about
that later let's say for for argument's
sake
that
this actually was a right and then we
could ask ourselves all right
who has actually enjoyed this right in
our long history in just in america i
mean leave the rest of the world apart
or who even enjoys that right in the
present
i mean i got myself blocked on twitter
for 24 hours because i suggested that a
politician who has you know against
covid uh uh you know measures should
hopefully you know
get what they deserve and i didn't even
mention getting kovid and uh you know
that was a consequence
now was i fearful of it no um but i
don't think that fear here has to be the
one driving thing we could talk about a
potential of being shamed or shunned and
you know i say things that that draw
feedback from people all the time and
i actually razz a lot of politicians
myself should should politicians be able
to like just outright lie in social
media without getting called out on it
maybe not you know maybe we have to ask
what's going on in the new york times
minds here the editorial staff they also
made a second massive claim and this is
about causality for the social silencing
and de-pluralizing of america which is
their terms that they're using there so
here's what they said
in large part it's because the political
left and the right are caught in a
destructive loop of condemnation and
recrimination around and somebody
already mentioned the word cancel
culture now this is a big big sweeping
claim as well
which
as we're going to see
doesn't really have a lot of
justification and requires playing very
fast and loose with terminology so we'll
talk about that in a bit
many on the left refuse this is their
words to acknowledge that canceled
culture exists at all believing that
those who complain about it are offering
cover for bigots to peddle hate speech
all right so
yes that's that there are people on the
left who do claim that there is no such
thing as cancel culture
um i actually think that you know
we we have to talk about two different
things which we're going to get to later
cancellation as a concept and then the
much bigger bigger claim about there
being a cancel culture let's say the
canceled culture actually does exist as
as some you know amorphous systematic
thing okay then maybe some people on the
left are denying that
they also say many on the right for all
their braying about cancel culture have
been embraced an even more extreme
version of censoriousness as a bulwark
against a rapidly changing society with
laws that would ban books stifle
teachers and discourage open discussion
in classrooms yeah if you've been
following american news you know that
this is actually
the case and it's not just at a state
level there's a lot of local things as
well
um
but you know
is this really the causality of a
chilling of public speech
i think this is overblown
the third point that they make and
here's here's another interesting thing
that they say
however you define cancel culture
now that we should pause on that however
you define cancel culture so anybody can
define cancel culture according to the
new york times
any way they want to right
which means that it's a it's kind of a
[ __ ] concept you know they say
americans know it exists in felix's
birth any time that the new york times
claims to speak for americans outside of
their little bubble be suspicious in a
new national poll commissioned by times
opinion and siena college again way up
you know in new york only 34 percent of
americans said they believed that all
americans enjoyed freedom of speech
completely the poll found that 84
percent of adults said it is a very
serious or somewhat serious problem that
some americans do not speak freely in
everyday situations because of fear of
retaliation or harsh criticism now
notice how we're playing fast and loose
with terminology here
being concerned about
consequences for speaking is not the
same thing as cancel culture
so claiming that this opinion poll shows
that americans know it exists and feels
its burden
yeah that's that's pretty sloppy right
that's a sloppy equation here
um you know
very serious or somewhat serious you got
also look at the poll you know how
representative is the poll there's all
sorts of issues here right and i think
that we should view the new york times
as representatives of the third extreme
position
on cancel culture
it's everywhere almost anything can
count as being canceled or at least the
fear of being canceled which is quite
silly you know
the new york times is really engaging in
a kind of hysteria here you know what we
call pearl clutching
that i think kind of distracts from real
issues that we need to worry about the
fourth point that they make that i think
is kind of interesting this is another
quote the editorial board plans to
identify a wide range of threats to
freedom of speech in the coming months
and to offer possible solutions oh well
thank you new york times uh none of us
have ever been thinking about this
before you and it's so great that we
have these you know elites to tell us um
you know what the problems are and how
we should deal with them and then they
go on freedom of speech requires not
just a commitment to openness and
tolerance in the abstract it demands
conscientiousness about both the power
of speech and its potential harms we
believe it isn't enough for americans to
just believe in the rights of others to
speak freely they should always find
ways to actively support and protect
these rights
this is like great news for like the
aclu i mean they could like start a new
era
or anybody else who's about you know
free speech and rights and stuff like
that now that the new york times is on
on the matter we'll finally get to the
bottom of it
now what am i doing there some might
actually consider that shaming the new
york times isn't that awful that i'm you
know
saying stuff like that using my free
speech to say that the new york times is
kind of silly here the the fifth point
that they make that i want to bring up
here's another quote the old lesson of
think before you speak has given way to
the new lesson of speak at your peril
you can't consider yourself a supporter
of free speech and be policing and
punishing speech more than protecting it
free speech demands a greater
willingness to engage with ideas we
dislike and greater self-restraint in
the face of words that challenge and
even unsettle us end quote now again
when have most of us in our lives
not had to like shut the hell up
so we didn't get fired or disciplined or
a bad grade or you know ostracized by
our friends and family or you know
avoided by people in our workplace who
hasn't
learned that think before you speak can
mean speak at your your peril you know
um
it's it's it's really quite silly to see
the new york times claiming this you
know greater
willingness to engage with ideas we
dislike many of us live in environments
where people are constantly spouting
ideas we dislike you know greater
self-rest strength in the face of words
that challenge and even unsettle us
again the new york times is so out of
touch
um in what world did the advice think
before you speak not for many of us
means speak at your peril i mean try
rooting for your favorite sports team in
you know uh various environments like go
to go to philadelphia for an nfl game
and wear your jersey for your team if
it's not the eagles and see what people
say to you and maybe even try to beat
you up um as i was plotting out my notes
for this i was remembering back in the
early 90s i used to have my army field
jacket and this isn't even speaking this
is just wearing a jacket and i remember
being at a bar and two marines wanting
to kick my ass because i was wearing my
army field jacket and they're marines
and you know marines and army people
don't don't really like each other at
least didn't back then
you know i mean when have we not faced
any sort of consequences and what's the
peril here you know uh speak at your
peril
is is
peril great danger is somebody gonna
kick your ass is somebody gonna like
break your teeth is somebody actually
going to cancel you in a real not not
sort of made up way you know because
being kicked off twitter that's not
being cancelled not if you can [ __ ]
about it on tv you know
is there a real danger or is it this
worry about being shamed and shunned you
know so we're going to come back to
these new york time points in a bit and
i see there's already a lot of questions
and comments here that i'll get to in a
bit but i want to say first this lens of
cancel culture
it's a distorting one it's really
you know if you want to talk about
canceling you can't be talking about
shunning or shaming because that's not
canceling it would have to be silencing
and it would have to be silencing not
just in one place
but across the spectrum right
so these issues have been issues a long
time before the new york times turned
their attention to them
and the points that the new york times
are making i think are basically
inconsistent with each other so this is
this is an interesting feature of a lot
of discourse about um
free speech cancel culture a lot of it
is is is sort of incoherent and
inconsistent
and it's often done in bad faith and i
i'm going to say
and this is kind of a big claim on my
own part i want to say that
i'm guessing that not everybody on the
editorial board at the new york times
was actually putting this out in good
faith but i don't really know but you
know free speech right we can all say
what we want
so many there's a lot of different ways
of looking at this vast topic of freedom
of speech going beyond the new york
times editorial and all these different
issues involved in it
i tend to think
and this may be something for another
discussion later on
that if you want to make sense out of
freedom of speech
focusing exclusively on a rights-based
perspective or right to free speech
outside of very local and determinate
kinds of situations turns out not to be
productive you get the kind of [ __ ]
that we have going on these days right
and it often just turns into shouting
matches right
um so i'm going to look a little bit
later at a broadly utilitarian based and
classic discussion and justification of
freedom of expression but also of
lifestyle in john stuart mills classic
work util
on liberty and we'll talk a little bit
about maybe utilitarianism later on the
work utilitarianism
so utilitarianism is a majorly important
and common perspective in moral theory
and business and policy making you don't
have to be a utilitarian per se to see
how it is used and useful and the basic
idea behind it is what's called the
greatest happiness principle
what's right is what tends to maximize
good outcomes and minimize bad outcomes
for the community understood as an
aggregate of people within the community
and everybody everybody's outcomes count
as you know one person
and so you know nobody gets a privileged
or prioritized
weight in that
and typically if you're going to do
things in a utilitarian way and this is
why we teach it in ethics classes it
requires some thoughtfulness and some
investigation of what likely outcomes
actually are and you know you can't just
go with first gut instincts about it
and in this discussion we're going to
put aside the silly and easily dealt
with academic objections like utility
monster or you can't calculate in every
circumstance because if you read bentham
and mill they actually address
stuff like that so
that's that's not really an issue
mill is a
second generation
reinterpreter of utilitarianism because
you know bentham brings it out and
bentham actually mills dad is is a good
friend of bentham so you know they're
they're introduced to this early on
and utilitarianism gets attacked from a
lot of different perspectives including
you know worries about the
oppression of the minority or
elimination of freedom of speech or
things like that right so
mill is a good person to look to
especially since he wrote on liberty
and before we jump into that i want to
do two other things i want to think
about
and and bring up um
what we could call these areas or
domains and we should think about how
free speech
applies within these right um one is as
somebody's pointed out as somebody
always points out freedom of speech in
america is really only about the
government well yes and no
um the first amendment is about the
government right and it has to do with
the government limiting free speech of
citizens um free you know
[Music]
free speech or speech under the first
amendment has got a pretty wide
interpretation you could say
i mean when you can count corporate
donations to candidates as free speech
you've really pushed the boundaries
quite a bit but let's let's leave
government interference
behind let's think about government
service
if you're a government employee do you
have complete freedom of speech can you
say anything that you like or should
there be some limitations i mean there's
clearly limitations in a whole bunch of
places where people have to sign ndas or
they're within a hierarchical structure
and they're told what they can say and
what they can't say
um
we can also talk about the workplace you
know whether we're in small businesses
or corporations or
anything like that
we can talk about the media itself you
know television cable
radio podcasts
i suppose you could consider youtube
itself a form of media then we have
social media platforms you know twitter
instagram
uh i suppose tick tock right i don't
really use tick tock much but you know
facebook all of these things um
[Music]
and you know there's restrictions on on
those and there you know i think that we
need to think of these
as different domains that might have
their own
governing you know rules uh involved
there we can also talk about education
you know uh k through 12 education uh my
own domain that i'm involved in in the
college in university and this this
encompasses a wide range of situations
including what we call the classroom
which is often not just the classroom
but also the
course management system and things like
that we can think about our neighborhood
or our apartment complexes other living
situations that we're in and we can
think about voluntary associations like
clubs or religious associations and then
we have you know like our families and
friend groups and stuff like that and
each of these is a different type of
situation
you know we can ask ourselves questions
like are rights to free speech absolute
in all of these or
you know
are they sometimes legitimately
restricted you know for example if
there's stuff that it covers in the
employee handbook and you decide to work
in a place
you know maybe you don't get to say
anything that you like while you're on
the job to customers right
and you know we have we also have to
think about who gets to decide is
exercising free speech does the [ __ ]
who wants to constantly interrupt a work
meeting by bringing up their political
views do they get to count that as free
speech or not
you know or the student who's you know
constantly raising and we won't even
make it political just you know stupid
[ __ ] that doesn't have anything to
do with what what's being studied if you
tell them listen uh
participation in this class is oriented
towards discussing certain topics
we're going to move on to those topics
are you censoring them i don't think so
you know
and so i think we need to think about
considerations of relevance and this is
something that often gets left out a lot
and there's a great piece in medium by
joshua adams the and it's called the
really boring non-cancel culture war
truth about free speech in college
classrooms i highly recommend it
he says this and i'm quoting from his
piece i think we fetishize debate
particularly in academia in ways that
aren't realistic
this discourse is more often than not
discourse between elites about a handful
of classes at a handful of elite
universities and does not reflect the
everyday mundane and unsexy material
reality of what happens in the vast
majority of college classrooms around
america or the west the vast majority of
time in most classes most of each
individual class and most of entire the
entire semester
debate isn't something that's happening
outside of pretty spec
pretty meta-specific instances
in the events that debates do happen
most professors guide the conversation
they make sure that students are working
with the same definitions for terms try
to bring it back when it gets too
tangential the only pushback really
comes when students get objective facts
wrong and give very bad reasoning
he goes on further you know
many people who seek or sought out
debate in college often have a certain
personality type major and affluent
background in my experience they aren't
always the heroes and high minds people
think that they are the average student
is likely in class worrying about paying
their tuition and if the degree is worth
the mass of debt not boiling over inside
because their professor is too liberal
and a queer student demands to be
referred to using they pronouns he's
totally on the mark you know i i'm
gesturing over to marquette university
and the other places here that i have
taught i can tell you that these worries
that about what happens at harvard or at
evergreen college those are you know
those are not what most professors and
most students are facing you know that's
the sort of crap that people who either
only belong to that bubble
or who know nothing about higher
education because they've avoided it or
they dropped out of it like our former
governor scott walker uh who was a
marquette dropout
who you know we don't have to go into
his
many many uh failures um people who
don't really know anything about
education but are buying into right-wing
talking points um believe this sort of
[ __ ] you know for the vast majority
of college students the real thing is
making sure that they're actually
getting value for their education and
that means that there isn't an awful lot
of debate going on there's certainly
discussion free speech is used but it's
not used in this antagonistic culture
warrior kind of way
so i think that's a good piece to look
at
um jon stewart mill um let's talk about
jeremy bentham first bentham
writes in his utilitarian uh you know
philosophy particularly in
you know the early work like the
introduction to the
principles of morals and legislation or
also in the nomography and deontology
talks about sanctions
now what are sanctions sanctions
are ways in which a person's
um
behavior is rewarded or punished
including whatever it is that they they
say
and bentham distinguishes four or five
different sanctions four in the
introduction five in the later works so
there's the physical sanction right uh
you wanna know whether it's a good idea
to poke yourself in your eye give it a
try and you know the pain tells you
don't do this anymore right
um you know some other more qualified
physical sanctions do i like to drink my
coffee black or do i like to drink it
with um some cream in it
um i prefer it with cream i could try it
black and then i'm like
not quite the pleasure that i want and
our life is full of these sorts of
things let's put those aside
then there's political sanctions
political sanctions come from political
institutions
they are the effects of law and
institutions on people so we can talk
about
freedom of speech you know being
restricted by political institutions
that's great okay so there's another
sanction put that one aside
then there is what he calls the social
or sympathetic sanction which is other
people's pleasures and pains affecting
the person and they can do so in a very
direct way like you know you say
something asshole-ish to somebody
for example when i was a kid my dad
pointed out to me
and i don't know what the context was
that when he was a kid my age his ears
stuck out and his classmates called him
dumbo and then i looked at him and i
said yeah you are a dumbo and i could
see the pain on my dad's face and then i
felt sorry and then i stopped doing that
and i apologize well that's what bentham
would call a sanction seeing somebody
else's uh pains and he would actually
call that the motive of benevolence you
know taking uh sadness in somebody
else's sadness or taking pain in
somebody else's pain this is what
happens with like decent people right
um
it can also be somebody saying hey
you're an [ __ ] i don't like that you
talk to me that way you know um or wow
you you have some really um
selfish points of view when it comes to
your own freedom of speech or things
like that right
uh then there's what what bentham calls
the moral sanction these are the effects
of public opinion or approval on the
acting person notice these are not
political
these are not just social these are sort
of a bigger picture thing so when
there's a pile on on twitter
on the new york times for posting a
boneheaded uh set of claims that we have
a absolute right to say whatever we want
without fear of uh any sort of
consequences and a lot of people weigh
in that's public opinion right that's
not a political thing that's a
public uh or opinion or there's a lot of
different classifications for it now
bentham thinks that these help to
determine a person's will
he says prospectively and
retrospectively right sometimes a person
thinks about what the consequences of
their action is going to be
like you know should i um you know go
outside and i'm in a concert and i
really need to go to the bathroom i get
outside of the concert and everybody's
you know walking away i need to take a
crap should i just like stop in the
middle of the street and pull my pants
down and do that now i might face a
political sanction for that right but
you know i would also rightly face a
moral or social sanction for doing that
and you know no matter how desperate i
am for going to the bathroom i might
actually like you know control myself
because i think prospectively about my
actions and then i don't do it and and
we can do this for you know things that
people are tempted to say right
um
[Music]
they also determine a person's will
retrospectively they you know as we
often say f around and find out right
you do something stupid and people call
you on it and you don't like the way
that feels well now you're not going to
do that anymore or maybe you might like
double down and say oh i have a right to
do this right so ideally these sanctions
should promote the principle of utility
now in terms of free speech how might
this work
and i'll tell you about a funny story of
mine right
when i was a kid
um i well i i i was i guess you could
say a kid i was 16 years old i got put
in a juvenile detention facility so you
can guess i was already you know
troubled and acting like a jerk
and i found that you know the staff
members didn't treat me with the same
sort of uh
you know affection and respect that they
treated some of the other people who
were in this short-term facility and i
asked them why and then one guy said
well i mean it's really simple act like
an [ __ ] get treated like an [ __ ]
quit acting like an [ __ ] and that'll
be fine for you and we could think about
the way this works for speech in many
respects right i mean if you're going to
say
things that you know are offensive in a
particular context then you know why
wouldn't people be responding using
their own free speech
in kind right so you know the social and
moral sanctions in utilitarianism are
distinct from the political and they can
perform some very valuable
service right
and um mill is concerned to address some
of the problems that could arise with
this because what are some of the
problems you know social conformity
right that that could be a big problem
um
so you know
three passages from on liberty that i
think are good to focus on if you
haven't read on liberty you definitely
should so the first these are all from
part one the first is what's called the
harm principle
he says the object of this essay is to
assert one very simple principle is
entitled to govern absolutely the
dealings of society with the individual
in the way of compulsion and control
whether the means be physical force in
the form of legal penalties
or
the moral coercion of public opinion
right so he's talking about the social
sanction there
and he says the principle is that the
sole end for which mankind are warranted
individually or collectively and
interfering with the liberty of action
of any other member
is self-protection the only purpose for
which power can be rightfully exercised
over any member of a civilized community
against his will is to prevent harm for
to others um his own good is not a
sufficient warrant uh this is a very you
know uh commonly referenced thing and he
says now notice this
there are good reasons for remonstrating
with him or reasoning with him or
persuading him or in treating him but
not for compelling him or visiting him
with evil in case you do otherwise if
it's something that's only harming
himself right but even if it is harming
himself
you can still
uh
reason remonstrate persuade and treat
right
so that's a very important uh point of
view right
second thing that he says is this
includes not just um speech but what is
what is this appropriate region of human
liberty he says it comprises first the
inward domain of consciousness demanding
liberty of conscience in the most
comprehensive sense liberty of thought
and feeling absolute freedom of opinion
and sentiment on all subjects practical
or speculative scientific moral or
theological the liberty of expressing
and publishing opinions may seem to fall
under a different principle since it
belongs to the part of conduct of an
individual which concerns other people
but being almost of as much importance
as the liberty of thought itself and
resting in great part on the same
reasons it is practically inseparable
from it
secondly the principle requires liberty
of tastes and pursuits of framing the
plan of our life to suit our own
character of doing as we like subject to
such consequences as may follow without
impediment from our own fellow creatures
so long as what we do does not harm them
even though they should think our
conduct foolish perverse or wrong
third from the liberty of each
individual follows the same liberty of
combination among individuals freedom to
unite so we've got you know
expression lifestyle um uniting right
so these are um these are some pretty
important
clarifications
and notice the importance of the
lifestyle thing if it's not actually
harming anybody think about gay marriage
for example you know
um
there are still conservatives who want
to overturn that here in the united
states and you know the arguments that
they give
according to mill's harm principle or
bad arguments you know unless they can
somehow show that somebody's actually
being harmed in it i mean and you could
if we want to joke around we can say the
thing that we said when gay marriage was
being legalized yeah why shouldn't they
you know have the same problems and
misery as every every heterosexual
couple who wants to get married right um
i mean the divorce rate here is is 50
so that's pretty bad
the third thing that mill says that
really
is suggestive
has to do with whether this is a
universal thing that has to apply to
everybody and he says
it's hardly necessary to say that this
doctrine is meant to apply only to human
beings in the maturity of their
faculties we're not speaking of children
or of young persons below the age uh
which the law may fix as that of manhood
or womanhood those who are still in a
state to require being taken care of
others must be protected against their
own actions as well as external injury
for the same reason we may leave out of
consideration those backwards states of
society
in which the race itself may be
considered as in its knowledge he means
the human race right and non-edge means
you know it hasn't matured yet liberty
as a principle has no application to any
state of things anterior to the time
when man kind of become capable of being
improved by free and equal discussion
but as soon as man kind of attained the
capacity of being guided to their own
improvement by conviction or persuasion
compulsion either in the direct form of
pains and penalties for non-compliance
uh is no longer admissible as a means to
their own good and justifiable only for
the security of others so it's still
justifiable
now think about this
in
our current society
is everybody really
mature enough
to engage in
full discussion
i mean if your brain has basically been
rotted by ideology that you just pair it
constantly and you can't actually like
take in
new information and you and you're like
totally distrustful of anybody who isn't
like you
you're kind of immature aren't you and
maybe
the things that mill is saying would
apply to them maybe we can go backwards
you know
um
he makes a couple other important points
and on liberty he thinks that there's an
overall good in even falsehoods being
out there in express so you know having
false opinions and and uh being
misinformed and then spouting that stuff
you know but the the overall good is not
like oh i have a right to say whatever i
want i have a right to my opinions no
would say well no you're stupid um
you're conducing to the overall good
because the truth
should be able to
come out of these discussions uh by
contrast to your stupid stupid things
that you're saying right or
ill-considered or foolish or ideological
or something like that he also talks
about um whether expression should be
censored or punished because of the mode
of expression he calls this
intemperateness and he gives examples
invective sarcasm personality meaning
you know attacks on the person or
polemic and he says
you know
i understand why people want us to be
more civil and nice to each other but
they're very often and he's saying this
in his time but this applies in our time
too they're very often so selective
about this
i mean if we're gonna have free speech
you got to accept that people are going
to call you a bozo sometime or make fun
of you or bring up you know if you're
going to tweet stuff and and then people
bring up your previous tweets and point
out to you that you're being
inconsistent and a hypocrite or even a
liar or something like that
you gotta roll with that you know
um the last thing i do want to bring up
is that you know this does extend to
lifestyle
you know what would be good examples of
things that do in fact harm other people
you know in my family growing up in the
the countryside we used to burn our
trash you know
if you move to the city you don't get to
burn your trash anymore because uh i
mean you probably shouldn't be burning
your trash we were doing all sorts of
environmental damage by that uh you know
you don't get to do that because it
impinges on somebody else um if you're
beating your children out of poorly
considered religious beliefs because you
really love that line you know spare the
rod and spoil the child and you ignore
all the rest of the you know scriptures
that that talk about love and things
like that or the need to set a good
example well maybe we we should
intervene in that because your children
are being harmed you know and your free
speech saying oh no i think it's for
their own good doesn't actually uh stop
that harm right so
coming back now to the new york times
editorial what would on liberty have to
say about this
i mean you know there probably is some
worries that we could have about being
canceled or cancelled culture but we
really should debate this this should
not be something that people get to
parrot all the time you know being
canceled should be more clearly defined
and used right there's a lot of people
who claim that they're canceled but
they're claiming that they're being
canceled on you know alternative media
and they're bigger than ever so they're
not being canceled they're actually
liars about cancellation right or we
have to say that it's a
relative term you know maybe you can be
canceled with respect to x and if you're
going to claim to be cancelled you
better really be canceled it it's not
people are being mean to you or you're
being criticized or some [ __ ] like
that you need to actually show that that
you've been deprived of some massive
opportunity that you can't get somewhere
else you know a real example of this
justine sacco and her her joke in 2013
about africa and aids that she tweeted
she wound up being excoriated on twitter
facebook and instagram fired from her pr
job um and it's interesting because
conservatives back then
were complaining about freedom of speech
and a witch hunt and stuff like that
she was fired from a pr job she was not
fired from being a janitor she was not
fired from something else
if your job is pr
maybe you know as a qualification of
that job you should have some good
social media discipline you know i i
mean
if we're going to use this term cancel
culture
and we're going to use it in a
non-ideological non-bad faith way it's
got to be something much more cohesive
and systematic and pervasive than just
isolated incidents of being canceled
there'd better be something that we can
point at that's real
is shaming and shunning part of cancel
culture no
shaming and shunning is not
de-platforming shaming and shunning is
not silencing shaming and shunning is
not the same thing as like you know
doxxing somebody right
um it's criticizing somebody it's it's
deciding to use your own
uh freedom
to
say things in return about them and to
say i'm not gonna have anything to do
with you you know if one of your
co-workers is a rabid racist uh you
don't have to go out for drinks with
them they're not canceling them you're
not you know restricting their free
speech in a way that's oh it's so awful
you know like the new york times is
worried about you're actually exercising
your own freedom in that case
um you know and so p maybe people
actually ought to be concerned with the
consequences of what they say and think
about the discourses and situation i
mean if you think that you should be
able to say anything at any time
anywhere you're kind of just an [ __ ]
rather than a free speech advocate it's
a fundamental kind of selfishness and
narcissism
i would say that should be called out by
other people that deserve shaming and
shunning you know uh
so this idea that people should have a
right to free speech you know to without
any fear of shaming and shunning that
that goes against like the whole
tradition basically of serious
discussions of free speech and it's
nonsensical ultimately because you know
the new york times themselves are making
moral claims here about who should be
allowed to you know
express what so
that is pretty much
all that i have to say here i'm gonna
we're gonna go longer on this one i'm
sure than we normally do an hour um and
now it's time for me to like start
responding to some of the many i
hopefully uh thoughtful in good faith uh
comments here so jb bell
very curious to hear your thoughts on
companies that hold near monopolies on
the press of our day um there are no
companies that hold near monopolies on
the press of our day there's many
there's many many outlets out there
um you know if you're talking about like
newspaper
and
radio companies there are there's
there's a lot more um conglomerates than
there ought to be and they do engage in
some censorship right sometimes they
just engage in crappy journalism like
our current you know
milwaukee journal sentinel has
really declined significantly in the
last 10 years
unfortunately after they got bought out
um you know the new york times itself is
definitely not what it used to be
um
but i i you know there isn't a company
that has a monopoly on the press we we
have lots and lots and lots of outlets
so i that to me seems kind of a
uh a non-issue right and if if we're
talking about social media you can say
well you know facebook controls facebook
yeah but if facebook controls facebook
and you don't like that go to twitter go
to instagram go to i don't know you can
even like
argue with people on pinterest or you
can be you can have your own discord
server
be on reddit there's all these different
alternatives and opportunities right
all right uh zeno of elea i don't know
much about politics read aristotle but
not his politics works any ideas for
starting off well read his politics you
know um there's like an entire world of
uh things out there that you could read
already says wait a second i'm supposed
to have a good faith discussion yeah now
so that's interesting right
we can impose that
as a condition
for getting to discuss issues of free
speech right are we restricting people
by doing that are we interfering with
their free speech i mean sure but it's
not like if i kick somebody off or
actually mark who's you know uh deleting
some of the the people who are making
[ __ ] comments here
um kick somebody off like they can't go
and write up whatever they want on their
own personal blog or shoot their own
video or you know they're not being
censored in any important way right by
being demanded to be in good faith
um
all right let's see what else we got
here
um jordan tahani it begs the question
meaning it raises the question because
begging the question is circular right
what is the role of shame in public
discourse yeah that's a big question
we're probably not going to explore that
all here that could be a whole other uh
thing it suffices to say um if you say
stupid you know clearly biased uh
misinformed things
um
maybe it's a good thing that you get
shamed you know i know i've certainly
benefitted by people
calling me out on stuff you know didn't
kill me
didn't destroy me psychologically
um oftentimes it you know made me say oh
i gotta back up and like
before i get into this discussion i'd
better you know better find out what the
hell's going on or figure out you know
why i'm wrong about this sort of stuff
um
brenda get what they deserve would be
interpreted as advocating violence could
be interpreted not would be interpreted
right there's choices there uh you know
uh it all depends on
which direction we want to take
something right and actually i'll just
go on record here
and say that um
i kind of think that people who are
interfering with any sort of covid
mitigation stuff and are openly
spreading misinformation
if they happen to wind up with kovid
well maybe they did get what they
deserve you know um because there's
plenty of other people who got coveted
who didn't deserve it and very often
these people uh who interfere with you
know
uh putting any sort of mask mandates in
place
shame other people get in their faces
about wearing masks
they're often you know causally in some
sort of complicated way responsible for
it so you know i think the key there is
deserve right
um
[Music]
brenda there are no sane players on the
far left or right well you know the far
left or right are not the majority of
people so that's kind of a non-starter
um
mark i don't think anyone sane believes
in absolute freedom of speech yeah
including jon stewart mill he doesn't
believe in absolute freedom of speech
the question is instead what kind of
speech should be excluded from the
public sphere and how we are to publish
transgressors and again we need to think
about what the public sphere is is the
public sphere
social media is the public sphere
college and university classrooms is the
public sphere
the workplace
you know we can go on and on and on is
it going out in the park
and holding up a sign is that the public
sphere what about putting a thing in my
window is that the public sphere right
we need to we need to treat these
different kinds of domains
differently from each other i think
right
um
all right let's see what else we get
uh
a lot of back and forth discussion here
that i'm going to skip over
all right brenda says cancel culture is
not about countering free speech with
better speech it's about going after
somebody's livelihood or employment so
their voice is removed from the public
sphere
yeah that that's true so
unless
i've been thinking about this a lot
we shouldn't call something cancelling
unless
some pretty high bars are met
one would be being like totally pushed
out of the public sphere right
so
getting kicked off of twitter is not
being cancelled not if you can go onto
tv and [ __ ] about it or write in your
blog about it or you know get to do
presentations about it or stuff like
that or go on somebody's podcast and
whine about it right
you're cancelled unless we want to say
that canceling is only cancelled with
respect to x right and in that case we'd
be using the term in a very very
restricted qualified way if we want to
use it in a broad way
you got to be kicked out entirely to be
cancelled
you have to have no place or only very
marginal places to get your message out
in order to truly be cancelled and there
have been many people who've been
canceled in the past in such a way you
know
including within you know the research
community you know science itself a lot
of people love oh science the scientific
method blah blah blah you look at the
actual actual history of science there's
a lot of like i don't believe this this
research that you're doing that turns
out to be completely true and somebody
doesn't get a university position and
doesn't get their stuff published
because of the old boys network who like
things the way they are right
and we can see that in a lot of other
things so there's there's like access to
the public sphere and then yeah we can
talk about the workplace if um
if you're calling for
um
[Music]
somebody to be fired from their position
and then you know blackballing them
elsewhere okay that's that's cancel
culture i have no problem well that's
cancellation still not cancel culture
unless you can show like an actual
culture
so
you know i'm willing to say that there
is cancellation that it happens
does cancel culture exist
the the verdict's out on that does
cancel culture in the way that that
people who use that term exist
no
no it's it's a boogie man
um
all right cola moose have you seen the
new batman movie i haven't seen the new
batman movie probably won't too i'm not
into superhero movies very much
um
secret secret asian dan what is politics
as a video about it at will employment
as the original cancel culture
that's not cancel culture i mean at will
employment uh means that you can be
fired at will if the employer wants to
fire you but it's not cancel culture
because you can go get a job somewhere
else
right
so i think we've got to be really
careful about how we're thinking about
using these terms
all right
mark
was talking about speech that is itself
destructive of the public sphere people
who use their speech to force others out
of the public should be shamed as far as
i'm concerned
yeah i mean um
there are there are quite a few people
involved like think about twitter pylons
right i mean think about that that lady
um
i mean there are two consequences for
her that i brought up socco right so she
made a really tasteless joke about aids
in africa which by the way the aids
organizations in africa were able to use
to actually get donations so there was
there was an upside to it
she really did get canceled both in
terms of work and you know like with the
the massive pylons on her um
was she was what she was doing
destructive of the public sphere no i
mean it allowed the mechanism of the
public sphere to to work on her poor
poor lady
you know uh what what she suffered was
uh quite disproportionate to the harm
done by whatever it was by by her
offhand tweet right
but there are a lot of people who are
trying to control the public sphere um
you know quite a quite a lot of them are
associated with uh
well-funded foundations and think tanks
and political action committees and our
you know uh uh political um
representatives and people like that um
you know uh so
there's something to be said there the
service branch
secret agent dan weighs in about service
branch disputes show the destructiveness
of jingoism taken to the max
they can sometimes they do sometimes
they don't i i have you know in my
family we have
army marine air force
and uh navy people and we all get along
you know we sometimes razz each other a
little bit but we don't try to beat each
other's asses or anything so
all right
um let's see
rob says
i read the pieces on stoicism and social
justice and honestly thought irvine's
essay was insufferable all this talk
about new ideas and how basically
marginalized people should shut up yeah
i mean william irvine is on the right
wing side you would say
um
and you know so he's referring to the
these pieces that we've gathered in
stoicism today selected essays volume 2
which originally ran
in the blog stoicism today
there's a dispute there between william
irvine and
eric scott yeah and eric scott attended
stoicon 2016
in the audience
as a graduate student with his
girlfriend
who
is black and sat there listening to
william irvine talking about how
microaggressions are really just you
know people being too sensitive and um
you know a real stoic would sort of buck
up and you know not be involved in all
this social justice thing and
you know
eric had a lot of good stuff to say
about that um
i mean to be a stoic you know there's
also this great case
that got brought up in britain right the
guy who is
who is calling his asian co-workers
greasy and who got disciplined and fired
and then claimed stoicism as the reason
why he did it and unfortunately the
british judge who didn't know anything
about stoicism went along with that and
all of us people who know something
about stoicism were like yeah that's not
stoicism
a stoic would not be an [ __ ] you know
um and if you know if you're a lot of
this is contextual right
um
if you know that people
are
tending to be
upset by something
um
you know unless there's like some some
clear reason to like throw it in their
face
you know maybe that's not the time to
bring it up right um
so yeah
uh zeno there's a youtuber named cosmic
skeptic who's a utilitarian there's lots
of people who are utilitarians the most
famous utilitarian right now would
probably be peter singer right
uh secret asian dan ari reflexiveness
pure utilitarians can't exist we don't
give a [ __ ] about that you know
like i said at the very beginning we're
not going to worry about silly academic
gotcha stuff about utilitarianism we're
going to talk about it as in a broad
sense
brenda if you sign a contract or
agreement to limit your freedom of
speech that's your choice
you can say that
unless you're signing something that has
so many long things that you
can't actually possibly read them all
like user agreements or if you're
coerced or we could go down the line of
things that could invalidate a contract
right
uh sean makes me think of the russian
chess players sergey
karjakin who supported the ukraine
invasion getting suspended by by fida
i mean yeah if you want to see some some
serious like restriction of freedom of
speech uh contemporary russia is a great
example there's many places you could
look at around the world it you know and
this there should be a sense of
proportionality probably to people who
are worried about or complaining about
their freedom of speech or other
people's freedom of speech being impeded
i think we should focus less on like the
extreme utopian thing of perfect
freedom of speech and we should look at
things on a continuum right
zeno says
youtube's guidelines is very
inconsistent not a surprise they don't
allow people to post things with sexual
stuff unless you're famous like uh or or
a rapper yeah there
you can say with social media in general
and you can also say this with media in
general
that if you belong to an elite
you probably get to get away with a lot
of stuff that people who are lower down
don't get to right
um not saying that's okay but that that
is that is quite true
um and you know you could think about
the content that's allowed in various
platforms
i mean youtube
is in large respect what they allow what
they don't allow is a i would say a
product
of the
uh
american
set of mores you know
so for example nudity right um should
um
being topless for
women count as nudity or not for for
youtube the answer is definitely yes
because here in america
uh that's generally the way we look at
things whereas in in some other places
um
you know it's it's not that big of a
deal right
um
so yeah there's there's some
inconsistencies there
um
let's see secret asian dan the times
does not allow hate speech but there is
a difference in hate speech and speech
that challenges us in ways that we might
find difficult or even offensive
yeah and it's up to the times to clarify
those distinctions i would say right
um
cola most people with empty minds may be
enlightened the bull with drugs at the
bottom is not yeah that's that's quite
true
zeno of aleia can someone write down the
book reference i mean the books that
we've referenced here are jeremy
bentham's introduction to the principles
of morals and legislation and jon
stewart mills on liberty
public domain you can easily google them
find them
i've got lots of videos on on both of
them
let's see
john holloway i think part of the
problem with bad classroom discussions
is that society
a fetish for an individual who argues
against the crowd i've met too many
people who think contrary equals
insightful yeah being being contrarian
is sometimes just being a kook or a jerk
you know it's it's not necessarily being
the social critic that we all need and
desire right there's a lot of that you
know and a lot of times people
who are doing that are not very original
they're just echoing somebody else's
talking points so i mean do i need to
have noam chomsky
or
you know tucker carlson pick whoever you
want from left or right
brought into my classroom
uh in sound bite form you know
disrupting our discussion about mary
wollstonecraft and how things are for
for women in society in the in the uh
1800s and today
probably not you know i mean
you know the other thing that that it
occurs to me
is that
people who spout stuff
and want to be involved in a debate they
often don't realize that so many other
people around them they're not hearing
this stuff for the first time
they've already heard it thought it
through and they're like yeah that's
garbage i don't i don't want to
consider that anymore you know do i have
to hear this stupid point for the 438th
time and respond to it again
you know
i don't think that we actually have a
duty to do that um
i mean if we're teaching a class
we have to treat each new batch of
students as a new batch of students it
would be unfair for me to say you know
somebody brings up an objection a plato
would be unfair for me to say you know i
already heard that 20 years ago i don't
have to deal with that deal with that
now but you know when it comes to a lot
of this stuff if people are just
regurgitating tired old things
we don't we're not under an obligation
to engage with them right
uh oh
brenda says don't google people crapping
in public yeah i imagine that would lead
to some
stuff that you don't want to
to see um
[Music]
all right john holloway says the
crapping and public example reminds me
of the famous pee-wee herman canceling
after he was caught playing with himself
in a portal theater
that's a good example yeah i mean but he
hasn't been totally canceled because
he's he's
back on you know in shows now
so sometimes cancellation wears off but
that was i mean it's interesting think
about the difference
in time
in era right
peter pee wee herman could be cancelled
um
he could be taken off the air he could
be not hired back
he could be effectively marginalized
back in the 90s fairly easily right can
you do that as easily now i mean if if
somebody
does something stupid and you know
offensive
and they get kicked off of their tv
shows right
they can start a podcast
they can
get on youtube
they can
do their own thing and there's going to
be all sorts of people lined up behind
them who are like opposed to their
cancellation and they'll buy t-shirts
and they'll buy all sorts of other merch
and stuff like that right
so
you know we we are kind of in an era
where it's harder to cancel people at
least in certain respects when it comes
to the employer thing
maybe it's easier to cancel people you
can you can find out where somebody
works quite easily whereas maybe in the
past it was harder to do that
all right um
and mark points out maybe the issue with
pb herman had more to do with the fact
that he was a children's entertainer
i think that was part of it you know
um
[Music]
i mean so mark says i guess the question
is are you okay having your kids watch
him knowing that he does that
and that does that would not be
masturbation as such because you know as
we know most people masturbate right
uh and uh those many of those who say
that they don't are just lying
so
you know i think we can assume for any
given adult
that they probably do that
and so you know
any any actor on a children's show
probably does that
the question would be do they go to a
porno theater and do that
i mean
i imagine porno theaters still probably
exist somewhere but
um
you know they've been seriously cut into
by the existence of the internet
um
that's probably enough on on that so all
right um
there's more about pee wee herman i'm
gonna see if we can skip down and find
some
some other stuff um
[Music]
brenda says mature in age but i'm not
responsible for others in maturity quite
true yeah um you know when it comes to
free speech
we're not responsible for what others
say unless we
choose to incorporate or endorse it i
suppose right
um john holloway points out we've been
canceling people for a long time social
media just made it happen faster and
more more publicly yeah yeah i mean
people have been cancelled
for for a very long time and generally
people who were already in a one-down
position could be easily canceled you
know if you were
speaking up at work and you were not
already in a protected or privileged
position you might get canceled right
if you got into a debate with a public
figure
and you were in the right and they were
in the wrong you might get canceled you
know uh in the sense of that we've
talked about before deprived of
livelihood or
pushed out of the public sphere and not
allowed anything but the most marginal
places to be this has happened a lot in
the past you know usually the
cancellation wasn't so much about you
know uh big people
who you know uh had a lot of power
although that seems to be the worry
about people with cancer culture these
days you know uh the elites are
suffering you know it was more often the
ordinary person right
so
all right um
ricky palios doesn't the republic cover
free speech you're talking about plato's
republic does it mention free speech
kind of it mentions parasia which is a
frankness of speech
which happens in a democracy and one of
the reasons why democracies tend to be
dysfunctional according to plato
of course you know plato is relying upon
that very freedom of speech to be able
to write the republic and disseminate it
and stuff like that so yes it does cover
about cover it
brian remember the hr department
considers offense to be taken not given
and constitute a form of harassment
it depends on which hr department you
know it's not as if every single hr
department is reporting to a platonic
ideal called the hr department some hdr
departments are totally ineffective you
know
there's plenty of cases out there where
we can see that some hr departments are
very centurious you know
depends on the institution
many hr departments dismiss claims about
harassment you know they say well you
know we all need to get along and stuff
like that so it really uh it really
depends doesn't it
um max i feel that there might be some
more new concern with shaming and
shunning especially in with the entrance
into the new age of international
politics no idea what that possibly
means
so um i'm going to pass over that
uh mf so you've been publicly shamed is
a good book that covers dispro
disproportionate retribution online yeah
it covers a bunch of cases
um i don't think it's like a great book
for you know like the whole general
topic
jb is talking about at will employment
at a minimum calling it at will as if
the employer's right to quit is equal to
the employer's right to fire them for no
reason is a ridiculous euphemism that's
quite true not being able to quit has a
name already and and interestingly
we had a case here
in wisconsin which is an at-will state
where health care workers were not
allowed to quit and moved to another
hospital
during the covid crisis
um showing that their at will employment
actually wasn't at will their
resignations were not accepted
um
barless isn't it funny we hear alt-right
advocating for free speech while
canceled culture is basically
a result of markets suited to fit the
consumer capitalism and liberalism
suddenly incompatible there's a lot of
incoherences here i mean a big
incoherence again is cancel culture is a
poorly defined term the new york times
to come back to the article did a real
disservice by saying you know people can
define cancel culture any way that they
want i mean if they if they really want
to get serious about this they should do
an editorial saying um what you're
calling cancel culture isn't cancel
culture
this over here is you know and and start
restricting it right and calling people
out for being sloppy and fast and loose
and bad faith in their their use of the
term right
uh jb bell irvine actually got booed at
that talk that was some free speech
shaming yeah it was mild booing it
wasn't like you know the whole place
turned against him the video for it's
available i'm pretty sure on the modern
stoicism website
um brenda
uh with respect to stoicism could not a
stoic speak out against an injustice to
himself for others stoics not only could
stoics did
um stoic
capital s not stoic small s of course
because uh small case s stoicism is just
a character trait and you know if you're
a real follower it's got an uppercase s
um
yeah but stoics were very clear i mean
read epictetus discourse he shames uh
not just his own students on occasion
but people who come to his place and
he's like listen buddy i can't do
anything with you or you know a local
father or the pro curator who got into a
tiff with the people uh in the the
theater you know and they booed him and
and stuff like that i mean epictetus
does that all the time seneca doesn't
pull punches um
and you know neither do aristotelians or
plaintiffs or you know
other people who think that justice
actually matters
um you know
all right uh paul western politicians
are using the threat of nuclear war to
effectively cancel any serious that's
[ __ ]
and he's here to be about nato closing
sky over ukraine
that's so silly
there isn't any cancellation of serious
debate it's going on all the time it's
happening in twitter i mean i see stuff
about it every single day i think that
you you you know you're probably using
cancel in a very weird way here
um so
mike says uh so true nothing
groundbreaking or politically incorrect
about heritage foundation talking points
really anybody's talking points by
virtue of being talking points are
probably not gonna be groundbreaking or
even very interesting
um
all right let's see here barliss says
canceling random russian people their
communities and culture in the west
actually does a favor to a guy like
putin and his politics of censorship um
you know
which random russian people have been
cancelled i mean this is this is where
we get to interesting things right so um
can we can we uh talk about dostoyevsky
yes we can just as much as you know when
when uh hume tower was having the name
hume taking on taken off of that did
that prevent anybody from reading hume's
treaties no
i mean if you want to read dostoyevsky
it's online
for free in the public domain i got
videos on dostoyevsky dostoevsky hasn't
been cancelled you know uh who else has
been cancelled i mean some people have
taken russian vodka off the shelf well
too [ __ ] bad there's a million other
kinds of vodka i'm looking up at our
shelf we've got tito's vodka you know uh
good enough right
i mean
this these sort of things you're gonna
use the word cancel it better means
something
right
so this this is a big problem
johan sig isn't part of the concern that
cancellation is done by a mob but a mob
that can't claim to be a majority by any
means also by powerful people with
political agendas
um
i don't know that that's the the concern
um i think that people who use the word
cancel sloppily
very often don't really know what
they're they're trying to say they're
you know they flail around with it
um i mean a mob what mob i mean are you
talking about people on twitter are you
talking about
you know people who happen to watch fox
news and get riled up about something
are they a mob
where are they gathering you know
um mob is being used in a very
metaphorical way there
um peop powerful people with political
agendas
yeah i mean when tucker carlson calls
for
somebody to be called out and he's
trying to cancel them
okay that's a person with a powerful
agenda when donald trump was doing all
of his nonsensical [ __ ] on twitter i
guess you could call it that um you know
people who fund think tanks which i mean
funding a think tank that's a big
investment and it takes a long time for
that to pay off because think tankers
are slow writers and and contributors
but i suppose that could lead to people
being cancelled
but again we have to be really really
careful
about
what we mean by cancellation you know
uh zeno uh what do you think of
christopher hitchens uh own free sun
free speech in his free speech debate if
you've seen it
christopher hitch oh own free speech
right
um
i i mean i don't i don't think i've seen
uh him involved in a debate i'm not a
fan of hitchens uh i know a lot of
people out there are but i'm not
um in all caps xz cnn is trying to
cancel putin again sloppy use of cancel
what the hell do you mean by it right
and how would cnn
cancel
a head of state
just ridiculous i mean shows exactly the
sort of thing that we're talking about
here
um
all right derek don't defend attacks on
the common russian people we're getting
off track here with worries about the
common russian people i mean who speaks
for them right
um
all right jason uh
recently purchased your book reason
fulfilled by revelation would love to
have you sign it if there's a way to get
a hold of you i mean it's very easy to
find my information out there
on the net it's very easy to find my
email that's a good thing to email me
about all right mark greg do you think
that when the languages of ethnic
minorities in nation states aren't
recognized as official state languages
that constitutes a form of oppression
and notice this is good not using the
word cancellation but oppression calling
things by uh more accurate names um yeah
i mean this is a big problem
mark is in south africa where this this
has been a significant problem for many
of the different languages it's a it's
an issue here in wisconsin where we've
had a lot of hmong immigration um you
know uh after the vietnam war this is
one of the most
uh this and minnesota and michigan a lot
of hmongs came here took a very long
time to get hmong language classes to be
offered uh very important to the
survival of that community which is
quite vital here in the milwaukee area
by the way
and we could go on and on and on about
you know different different languages
so i i think that you know
failing to provide or even like
discouraging the use of languages can be
quite oppressive
ali power
i think your point about dostoevsky is
well made however a month's performance
of swan lake in dublin was recently
pulled completely at sad and crude it's
more stupid than anything i mean what
prevents you from going online and
seeing
any one of many performances of swan
lake
it's it's not like swan lake has gone
away right um
so
either we're going to use the word
cancelled in a way that actually means
something or we should probably stop
using it you know
so
all right so
we don't have a lot of new questions and
comments this is probably a good time to
draw to a close because i do have
another
online event for patreon supporters of
the half hour hegel project that i'm
gonna have to get to in a little bit of
time and i should eat something for for
lunch and check on my little cat sassy
many of you know about her because i
post about her constantly
but this has been a great discussion and
there's a lot of other issues i think to
explore
the new york times thing has provided us
with a good opportunity to reconsider
these questions about free speech i i
highly advise all of you to check out
john stuart mills on liberty it's a
classic document in discussions about
free speech ricky mentioned plato's
republic that would also you know book
eight would be a good place to go to
think about um
speech and its relation to the political
community
somebody else mentioned aristotle's
politics
that's another good place to go and
think about these sorts of things so um
i look forward to
great you know discussions next month
i'm not sure what topic we'll pick it
might be another thing connected to free
speech to follow up with this but thanks
for all the the questions and comments
and i will see you
next time in the ether